[Applause]
[Music]
located between the Pacific Ocean and
the Caribbean Sea we could say Colombia
is something like the entry and exit
door of South America and you know what
well this this is Colombia the long and
cheerful beaches of Santa Marta the
lower Hira desert the inaccessible the
concern capital of the leafy Colombian
Amazon rainforest then there are the
islands of San Andreas and providencia
the coffee belt of Quin do caldrons and
razor alder and then there are of course
the vibrant cities of midian Cali or
barren quia and we can't forget about
the historical and proud Cartagena or
the frantic Bogota those are being the
great capital city of the country that
dear viewers with its Candelaria and
it's incredible museums of golden arch
will leave you absolutely speechless yes
we can't really be surprised that more
and more companies are making Colombia a
100% must visit destination well as you
might have guessed this video is not
going to be about tourism in Colombia
not at all it's politics that we do here
at visual politic I mean it's right
there in the name
may 28th
will have its next presidential election
and by August 7th whoever wins will have
begun his new job Juan Manuel Santos the
current president cannot run again as he
has reached his two-term limit
so as Santos this time is coming to an
end with this video we want to take a
look ahead and find out what kind of
Colombia he is going to leave to his
successor we're going to have a look at
the great things as well as a not so
great today's Colombia a gambling man a
great poker player and part of one of
the most influential families in
Colombia this is Juan Manuel Santos even
his great uncle
Eduardo Santos was president of Colombia
in the late 30s his family also owned
example the most influential newspaper
in the country in fact the very same
quantum annual Santos was for a long
time deputy director and a columnist at
the newspaper what we are trying to say
is that this family a well never lacks
influence money or power
but after two turns the 7th of August
2017 marked the end of his time as
president and to be honest his level of
popularity is pretty much rock-bottom
this is even after winning the Nobel
Peace Prize due to the deal that he got
with FARC
the latest poll numbers when we're
making this video show that 65 to 75% of
Colombian people disapprove of his
governance so the question now is how
does a Nobel prize-winning leader have
such strong disapproval ratings from his
own people
granted us to do with his broken promise
about the peace deal with FARC remember
he assured them that it was going to be
the Colombian people and no one else you
were going to have the last word on the
deal and well let's just say that
Santos forgot all about that Colombia
referendum voters reject peace deal with
FARC guerillas Columbia and FARC sign
new peace deal this time
skipping voters bus apart from all of
this if there is really something that
can make him have such low ratings well
well I would have to be the economy yeah
during the last decade this specific Q
Merkel's Colombia well you know it used
to have quite strong growth and it even
became one of the most thriving of the
Latin American countries however lately
things have been a little bit different
actually they've been really quite a lot
different I mean have a look at this
chart
plate Columbia is facing a situation of
slowdown which is really much closer to
what we've called stagnation the latest
growth figures show a year-on-year
increase of slightly above 1% and 2017
forecasts don't seem to be that much
better at all Lumbee --is economic
growth rate will be 1.5 percent in 2017
according to BBVA research as you can
see this is really not a good figure
especially if we consider that most of
the richest countries are growing at
higher rate the United States Canada
Spain Germany UK all of them will grow
more than Colombia in 2017 and well you
know it's kind of supposed to be there
when you're a poorer country you grow
more this is because of something that
is called economic convergence so well
now the question has to become what's
going on in Colombia any blame this
situation on the fall of oil and
commodity prices and you know in a way
this is sort of rice but there are some
nuances that we do need to consider now
it is true that at its climax in 2013
oil did represent more than 50 percent
of all the country's exports more than
30 percent of all foreign direct
investments and more than 20 percent of
public reserves but it's also true that
for many years thanks to the high oil
prices the government of Colombia has
had more resources than it's ever had
before resources that could have been
used to boost a productive and
competitive economy unrelated to those
original commodities and this is
something that the Santos administration
seems to not really have done perhaps
this is because they've been dedicated
is almost exclusively to that peace deal
with fog anyway let's now have a look at
what are the main weaknesses of the
Colombian economy
[Music]
disastrous infrastructure the news
Colombia has been should we say it there
almost a failed state in many areas if
you use our areas that were controlled
by warlords guerrillas militias and
narcos all of those alternative things
so now imagine how difficult it would be
to manage such a country and build
complex
infrastructure there but really the
reality is that that's not the whole
story the reality is that infrastructure
has never been a major priority for any
Colombian government and the result of
this it's pretty obvious the
infrastructure in Colombia well it's
really really bad today to describe
Colombia's infrastructure we can use
really any other word the dreadful most
of their paved roads they're in a state
of total disrepair and well what's the
result of all of this and do pay close
attention to this because well it's
almost unbelievable moving a container
within the country is twice as expensive
as in Mexico or Bolivia and four times
more expensive than in Argentina Chile
or Peru in fact the situation is so
disastrous that freight transport
between the Colombian ports of buena
Ventura and Bogota is three times more
expensive than moving the same load from
a Rotterdam to Franklin
interestingly there are some reports
that claim that sending a container from
Carter haina to Bogota costs three times
more than sending it to Shanghai so now
you can probably imagine all of the
effects that this has on supply costs
prices and the competitiveness of
Colombian companies according to a
recent OECD report Colombia is the third
world most expensive country from which
to explore containers after Venezuela
and Russia
that's why Juan Manuel Santos decided in
2010 to make changing this his top
priority and it is true that his
government has just released the biggest
infrastructure plan in the history of
Colombia a private Co funded plan which
under a concessionary system is actually
pretty attractive estamos construyendo
el programa de infrastructure de más
grande OS Pretoria
yes this planet actually seems to be
well designed but after seven years it's
just a bit too late and it still comes
with many problems Viviana stirring his
two terms
Santos achievements really haven't been
as good as he promised that they were
going to be bureaucracy and taxes both
the World Economic Forum and the World
Bank concerned that Colombia is one of
the countries with the highest taxes on
companies in the world which is
obviously something that doesn't help
companies to grow and develop according
to the paying taxes reports that every
year PricewaterhouseCoopers publishes to
the total of all taxes that a Colombian
company has to pay is sixty nine point
eight percent of their pre-tax profit
[Music]
that's almost 70 percent which is
significantly higher than in countries
like Germany in Spain the United States
to the earth it's pretty insane as I
mean that's not even mentioning the
bureaucracy which has an almost equal
level of pure insanity one day we're
really gonna have to make a video about
the passion for the Yurok recei the
Latin America seems to have that because
it would be really long we're not going
to touch on it in today's video it's
just too huge of the topic but what we
can say is that on an average day in
Colombia 15 rules and three decrees are
issues yes really every single day and
not just that but according to research
conducted by the University of La Habana
more than 30 percent of the laws passed
are useless and just create costs for
Colombian society and so what ask why
Manuel Santos d'Antibes solve all of
these issues well he has done almost
nothing in fact he has made the
situation even worse
[Music]
the persistent violence it is true any
aspects related to security are
improving in Colombia the uptick in the
tourism industry in the country is
pretty good evidence of that in 2016
five million tourists visited the
country which is twice the number from
2010 and almost ten times the number
from 2000 which is certainly not bad
however despite this in many areas of
the country the situation it's not
really improving according to the United
Nations in the Colombian conflict
analysis Resource Centre there is still
violence in the most affected areas of
the country that is the FARC peace deal
has not substantially improved the
situation in these areas in fact for
example coke it's on growing and cocaine
refining is that its absolute highest
think just have a look at this chart
[Music]
so well now you might be wondering how
did possible that violence levels and
these production of illicit substances
has not been reduced since the
government's deal with FARC
well that's because despite all the
marketing from the government and while
the violence by FARC was huge it
actually represented less than ten
percent of the nation's total violence
and moreover the areas that FARC have
left have not been occupied by
government institutions for by other
narco and militia groups some of them
even having a mutual agreement with FARC
after all the business it's still very
attractive now the peace deal left many
things up in the air and that's why
these so-called peace dividend is not
giving results as big as the government
promised now to be fair though not
everything has been totally bad under
Santos's presidency
[Music]
the best of the Santos administration we
have to admit that Juan Manuel Santos
has achieved some pretty good things
his government actually brought Colombia
to the Pacific Alliance and this is
another thing we're going to talk about
in an upcoming video so do not forget to
subscribe hit that button below and of
course this foreign agenda has been a
great strength of this government
Colombia today is more open to the world
than it ever has been before so that
poverty has been reduced considerably
the country has attracted lots of
foreign investment but despite all of
this our impression here a visual
politic is that the arrival of a new
government can really be a positive
turning point for Colombia when Juan
Manuel Santos took office the country
seemed to be ready to tackle a real
process of transformation and their oil
resources meant that they had the
ability to pay for it however this above
yes it simply hasn't been achieved in
fact it's kind of in the opposite Santos
leaves a weak economic Colombia and many
more future prospects than current
realities so now we'd love to know your
opinion wanting you think the future of
Colombia will be how would you rate
samples of the president well you can
leave your opinion in the comments below
and also in this quick survey and if you
enjoyed this video you can let us know
by hitting that like button also do
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided these vocals
in this episode though we're not mine
and as always thank you for watching
you
[Music]